[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans la
grande interwiew depuis trois ans
johanna clairement est devenue la
nouvelle égérie de la chasse elle en
fait la promotion sur les réseaux
sociaux et représentent différentes
marques de ce milieu cent trente six
mille abonnés sur instagram c'est ce
qu'on appelle une influence euse qui
espère donner une autre image de la
chasse mais affiché et défendre une
telle passion suscite forcément à des
polémiques quand on sait que 84% des
français trouvent cette pratique
dangereuse et cruel pour les animaux
d'après un sondage ipsos une activité
quand même pratiqué par environ 1,1
million de français johanna clairement a
accepté de répondre à nos questions dans
est la grande interview
johanna clairement bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté sent-il interview on le sait
c'est un sujet qui déchaîne les passions
on va justement en parler avec vous mais
tout d'abord j'aimerais un petit peu
parler de votre parcours atypique vous
avez vingt trois ans vous êtes étudiante
en master détroit des affaires et vous
avez une passion la chasse d'où vient
cette vocation
alors d'où vient cette vocation
c'est un petit peu atypique
effectivement parce que personne ne
chasse chez moi donc j'ai absolument
qu'un membre de ma famille qui est
chasseur et j'ai découvert sain dans ma
première année de lycée donc quand
j'étais en seconde et je suis parti
découvrir la chasse au sanglier avec des
camarades de classe et ce à partir de ce
moment là que je me suis à chasser par
moi même et justement comment a réagi
votre votre entourage aux familles vos
amis
j'étais étonné ils étaient étonnés et
puis après il ya eu diverses
il ya eu diverses réactions ma famille a
été étonné mais il a accepté sans à 100
sans en faire toute une histoire j'ai
certains amis qu'ils ont un petit peu
mal pris d'autres qui ont trouvé ça
génial donc ça dépend il ya eu un petit
peu de tout dans les réactions
alors vous raconter souvent cette
anecdote vous avez 16 ans et pour noël
vous recevez un cadeau oui oui oui
effectivement la première carabine gelé
reçu pour noël c'est un cadeau de mes
parents est ce que c'est ce qui a
peut-être déclencher l'envié d'aller à
la chasse finalement mais disons que
j'avais commencé à chasser c'est pour ça
qu'on a offert cette carabine papale
inverse pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
opté pour un pseudonyme
j'ai opté d'un pseudonyme tout
simplement parce que j'ai conscience des
dangers d'internet et surtout sur un
sujet comme ça comme la chasse qui est
controversé aujourd'hui j'ai pas envie
d'associer ça à mon vrai nom je pense
que c'est bien de dissocier les deux
pour se protéger
vous dites la chasse est plus qu'un
hobby c'est une façon de penser de
concevoir la vie c'est mon style de vie
pour des personnes qui ne chasse pas
habituellement
la question peut paraître candide mais
qu'est ce que vous aimez dans la chasse
qu'est ce qui vous plaît en fait je
pense que toutes les parties sont très
intéressantes alors effectivement il ya
la traque de l'animal c'est quelque
chose de très fort il ya le moment du
tir qui est aussi un moment un moment
fort le le plaisir de le consommer bien
sûr de le partager avec ses amis aussi
c'est vraiment un tout et je ne pourrais
pas vous donner le moment précis qui
suscite le plus d'émotion chez moi c'est
vraiment ce tout qui parlera pompili la
ministre de l'écologie et contre
l'interdiction de la chasse elle estime
qu'il faut des chasseurs pour préserver
est la biodiversité ce que selon vous la
chasse peut-elle être bénéfique à la
biodiversité
si oui comment c'est une notion que les
anti chasse ne comprennent pas forcément
bien sûr la chasse c'est bénéfique
évidemment en baisse il ya énormément de
facteurs il ya l'aspect régulation et
puis il ya aussi l'aspect aménagement du
territoire c'est vraiment un tout et je
pense que si aujourd'hui on arrive à
plus ou moins trouver un équilibre entre
la l'urbanisation l'agriculture et puis
les espaces naturels c'est grave grâce à
la chasse et grâce aux chasseurs
mais est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on peut être
défenseurs du climat de la nature et des
animaux et en même temps aimait la
chasse
bien évidemment je pense que c'est très
complémentaire justement bien sûr c'est
avoir conscience justement des
populations de comment les gérer des
espaces de vie dont ils ont besoin et
leur apporter au maximum ce dont ils ont
besoin pour s'épanouir réguler donc
prélevé un certain nombre d'animaux bien
précis pour la survie de l'espèce parce
que c'est toujours pareil les les
milieux naturels se sont de plus en plus
réduit pas du fait des chasseurs mais du
fait des êtres humains de façon générale
et tout ça va il faut adapter la gestion
et cette adaptation de de cet équilibre
c'est en grande partie le chasseur qu'il
fait en aménageant des espaces
spécifiques en réintroduisant parfois
des espèces en régulant exactement les
individus qu'il faut pour maintenir un
équilibre donc il ya beaucoup d'enjeu et
bien sûr le chasseur est un grand
facteur de ça aujourd'hui les
associations de défense animale elles
sont de plus en plus présente sur le
terrain les réseaux sociaux dans le dans
le les médias aussi il y à ce rythme et
c'est le référendum d'initiative
partagée en faveur du bien-être animal
est-ce que c'est des prises de position
qui vous interpelle il propose d'arrêter
beaucoup de choses
et qu'est ce qu'on fait à la place par
exemple sur l'élevage intensif moi c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose qui me
touche particulièrement quand je vois
des vidéos par exemple de l214
on voit des animaux en batterie etc
c'est vrai que c'est pas une vie digne
et c'est pas quelque chose qui me plaît
je veux justement pas participer à ça en
revanche comment on va faire pour
nourrir tout le monde est ce que en
n'empêchant cela la vie dans ne viendra
pas de notre pays voilà qu'est ce qu'on
propose concrètement en relation avec le
rip justement il ya ces associations qui
sont actives sur le terrain est-ce que
selon vous il ya des méthodes des
méthodes anti chasse qui sont un peu
limite voire exagérée
je pense qu'il ya déjà pas mal de
méthodes qui sont exagérées oui on a pas
mal de deux lieux de chasse et de
miradors qui ont été détériorés par des
anti chasse des espèces de pièges qu'ils
ont fait pour que les chasseurs tombe
etc
il ya aussi des personnes qui se
déplacent je pense notamment à la
vénerie où ils vont aller essayer de
bloquer l'action de chasse donc oui ce
n'est pas très fair play
il ya aussi tout l'aspect réseaux
sociaux où ils font passer défaut
d'information des faux messages donc
aussi non effectivement je pense qu'ils
vont trop loin il ya cette loi du 6
février 2015 qui reconnaît l'animal
comme étant un être vivant doux et de
sensibilité est ce que vous aussi en
tant que chasseuse vous le voyez de
cette même manière et ce que vous avez
finalement le sentiment de respecter
entre guillemets l'animal quand vous
êtes à la chasse personnellement oui
j'ai un grand respect pour les animaux
et je pense qu'effectivement
se nourrir d'un animal qui a été élevé
il a grandi dans son milieu naturel à
l'état sauvage c'est le plus grand
respect qu'on puisse lui apporter juin à
cannes on est clairement quels sont vos
limites et ce qui est des méthodes des
pratiques qu'en tant que chasseuse vous
n'encouragez pas je pense par exemple à
la chasse à la cour ou est ce que
finalement quand on est chasseur on ya
un panel de 2,2 d'activité dans la
chasse qu'on peut s'accorder est-ce que
selon vous il y a des limites
est-ce qu'on vous avez des méthodes que
vous les
les limites sont uniquement celles que
chacun s'impose en accord avec sa
conscience
personnellement il n'ya pas j'ai pas
encore pratiqué deux types de chasse et
en ressortant je me suis dit non ça ça
c'est vraiment horrible je le ferai plus
ça m'est jamais arrivé j'ai pas testé
tous les modes de chasse mais je pense
que voilà chacun chacun a une
sensibilité différente et trouve de
l'intérêt plus ou moins prononcé dans
certaines pratiques de la chasse est
moins d'autres donc après c'est à chacun
d'eux de décider aujourd'hui
selon des ong la chasse et la cause de
disparition de certaines espèces
quel est votre avis les avis sont assez
mitigées ce soit des antilles sachets
anti chasseurs ou justement des gens qui
encouragent la chasse jeu disons que ça
dépense jusqu'à quand on remonte mais là
dernièrement je ne vois pas d'espèces
qui a disparu à cause des chasseurs
justement j'ai j'ai bien l'impression
que les espèces sont sont en grande
partie conservée grâce à la gestion des
chasseurs enfin voila quand il par
exemple on parle beaucoup des grives etc
mais c'est tellement insignifiant au
final les chasse dont ils font part sur
l'écosystème sur la préservation de
l'espèce honnêtement je n'ai pas
d'exemple en tête qu'ils puissent qu'ils
puissent valider le fait que les
chasseurs sont sont responsables de
l'extinction de certaines espèces
est ce que vous comprenez qu'il y a qu
il y a
une partie des français qui sont contre
contre la chasse je le comprends pas ce
qui étant donné le contexte actuel et
avec toute la bonne propagande que les
anti chasse faune je comprends qu'il ait
une partie de l'opinion publique qui est
basculée en revanche quand on reprend
les chiffres là les 80 vous allez
annoncer 84 que vous avez annoncé tout à
l'heure
bon laissons d'alger était quand même un
petit peu orienté et c'est donc moi
personnellement les sondages je n'y
crois pas beaucoup je crois aux réalités
du terrain yannick jadot a justement
indiqué qu'en france il faudra sortir de
la chasse et il a considéré que voilà
cette pratique ne devait plus être un
loisir qu'est ce que qu'est ce que vous
lui répondre mais je lui répondrai que
pourquoi est ce que il faudrait sortir
de la chasse je pense que ça fait partie
de notre patrimoine culturel français
c'est une tradition c'est quelque chose
de très beau d'ancestrales sans la
chasse on ne serait pas là ni vous et
moi donc donc pourquoi pour la saison
2010 9 2020 il ya eu elle il ya eu des
accidents et on en dénombre 100 cas en
1941 victimes causées par par exemple
des mauvaises manipulations d'armes
on a des mauvais tir c'est plus que
l'année dernière est la plupart des
victimes sont des chasseurs mais pas
toujours
est ce que c'est une passion qui va
finalement peut être dangereuse c'est
une passion qui peut être dangereuse
mais comme comme n'importe laquelle et
puis je trouve que les accidents de
chasse quand même sont relativement
faible par rapport à d'autres activités
par rapport à des accidents de la route
et par rapport à beaucoup d'autres
choses ceci étant effectivement
manipulation d'un mais c'est ça fait
référence à la sécurité c'est important
que les règles de sécurité soit
renforcée pour éviter au maximum les
accidents inutile là je sais que
dernièrement à partir de maintenant je
crois
tous les dix ans les chasseurs devront
passer une formation de sécurité c'est
quelque chose de très bien effectivement
je pense qu'il ya des efforts à faire
pour qu'ils aient de moins en moins
d'accidents aujourd'hui vous avez vingt
trois ans vous êtes une femme qu'est ce
que vous espérez apporter justement à ce
monde de la chasse qui était un petit
peu entre guillemets vieilli
et qui était sur des bases très
traditionnel il ya quelques années je
n'ai pas la prétention d'apporter quoi
que ce soit mais je pense que c'est
normal aussi des gens de ma génération
des femmes il y en a de plus en plus moi
c'est vrai que je rencontre beaucoup de
jeunes à la chasse alors oui c'est vrai
que la moyenne est assez élevé mais
pourtant sur le terrain on se rend
compte qu'il ya pas mal de jeunes qui
accompagne qui s'y intéressent etc
et si je peux aider avec avec ce que je
fais sur les réseaux sociaux et serra a
montré un autre aspect de la chasse et à
donner envie à certaines personnes de la
découvrir
ça me fait très plaisir en 1975
l'hexagone comptait un peu plus de 2
millions de chasseurs aujourd'hui on est
au défunt à environ 1,1 million de
chasseurs en france
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est un
loisir qui serait peut-être amenés à
disparaître c'est possible honnêtement
je ne je ne sais pas mais il faudra de
toute façon si c'est le cas trouver une
autre solution pour pour accomplir les
tâches que font les chasseurs
aujourd'hui on a l'exemple du canton de
genève où finalement maintenant c'est
l'état qui va chasser un chat c'est
réguler le gibier la nuit pour être à
l'abri des regards
voilà je sais pas si c'est forcément la
bonne solution est ce que ça pourrait
arriver je ne peux pas vous dire c'est
c'est une bonne question mais j'espère
pas merci johanna clairement d'avoir été
avec nous et d'avoir accepté de répondre
à nos questions sur un sujet qui peut
être parfois compliqué à aborder merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous merci de
votre fidélité vous pouvez revoir cette
grande interview sur rtl france panthére
[Musique]
oui